I hate to tell you I told you so but I
told you so
when the White House in the GOP failed
to act on the Trump immigration agenda
in the first hundred days of his
presidency his pledge to build a wall
would be jeopardized
Trump's initial instinct which is
usually spot on was to veto that omnibus
bill last year I'm telling you he was
right then
but Paul Ryan and Mitch McConnell
promised him that they would get this
wall funded in full in the lame-duck
session if that was necessary well big
shocker
that never happened so after speaker
Paul I need to spend weekends at home
Ryan handed the majority to the
Democrats well the president faced an
even higher wall of resistance a lame-o
border deal was announced right before
the president took to the stage in El
Paso last night and by the morning the
details started trickling in I have to
study I'm not happy about it
it's not doing the trick but I'm adding
things to it then when you add whatever
I have to add it's all it's all gonna
happen we're building a wall and now I'm
saying we're finishing a wall
well that won't happen though not unless
the president finds the money elsewhere
or declares a national emergency which
will immediately be challenged of course
by the left in court and tonight after
speaking with one of the Republican
architects Richard Shelby senator from
Alabama the latest deal the president
tweeted was just presented the concept
in parameters of the border security
deal by hardworking Senator Richard
Shelby looking over all aspects knowing
that this will be hooked up with lots of
money from other sources
we'll be getting almost 23 billion
dollars for border security regardless
of wall money it is being built as we
speak we'll get into that in a little
bit but so what's in this deal what's
really in it the official language
hasn't fully been released I love this
doing this at the last minute try to
rush it through but here are some of the
basics of the deal as reported one point
375
million dollars for barriers that are
not called but look a heck of a lot like
the steel you know slanted structure
where barrier that Trump had already
approved second an average daily cap of
40,000 520 beds for detaining illegals
now that's almost nine thousand fewer
than we're detaining now but Trump would
have the authority to boost that number
pulling the money from other sources now
there's more to it too but it's simple
to see what's going on here the
Democrats ultimate goal is to codify
catch and release where if an illegal
makes it into the country he or she will
be welcome to stay along with any child
he or she brings with them across the
border now what does this do this is not
a difficult concept right it only
encourages more illegal immigration now
remember the president asked for 25
billion dollars last year for the wall
and a bunch of other reforms as well
that made a lot of sense but the Dems
wouldn't budge on issues like chain
migration or those diversity visas they
wouldn't go near it
then in December now moving into the
lame-duck session he asked for one-fifth
of that yeah I'm still pretty good at
math sort of it's five billion of the 25
billion now he perhaps thought that this
would become some type of annual wall
expenditure well fat chance been a water
wall they never wanted a wall but on the
bright side and I have to look at the
glass half full here the current deal
does expose just how far left the
democrat party has gone on the issue of
illegal immigration they've gone from
this we simply cannot allow people to
pour into the United States undetected
undocumented unchecked and illegal
aliens should not be treated the same as
people who entered the US legally we
must control our borders must protect
our borders to this
[Applause]
[Music]
oh really
so walls kill people well last year
there were 1247 people slaughtered in a
vicious fashion many of them by the
cartels and other criminals across the
border in Juarez
that was a 62% jump from the year prior
it's a killing field there so bado can't
possibly mean we should tear down the
current wall in El Paso can t well think
again remember this Jim that then
congressman will work sent out in 2015
it read tear down this wall oh boy
that's a that's a keeper well I can tell
you that the people we met in El Paso
last night they disagreed vehemently and
an underreported fact is that about half
of the audience at the Trump rally were
themselves Hispanic and they most
certainly do not want the wall between
the cartel run Juarez and El Paso torn
down no way
they love their peaceful community it
was a really fun place to be
we loved meeting the folks we met there
last night they don't want any part of
Juarez's way of life with beheadings and
bodies that have been dumped in the
street last year Juarez had 1200 murders
El Paso right next door a few feet away
had 23 murders walzwerk
actually there's nothing like them for
what we're talking about we want to stop
drugs we want to stop traffickers we
want to stop criminals from coming in
walls save lives now of course as much
as we wish things were different
the fact of the matter is Trump is
vowing to continue this fight right
through the 2020 election about the wall
and keeping our country safe
and another shutdown would have probably
ended up hurting the president
distracting from this booming economy
and we're here in Texas it is off the
charts and there's a lot of other great
news as well that would be distracted
from if this thing continued in a
shutdown form including the China
negotiations going on right now in
Beijing and also let's not forget while
Trump isn't getting everything he wants
and definitely not what most of us want
Democrats are also breaking Pelosi's
pledge situation which you would accept
[Music]
well try one point three seven five
billion dollars she might not want to
call it at all but that's what it is and
that's not all bad and that's the angle